let's go next to lucas from copenhagen
lucas you're on the air
yeah can you hear me yes i can alright
cool yeah i wanted to ask you something
about uh fiscal policy uh
especially right now uh with the new
administration
uh in the us so um from what i can tell
um the the spending of the biden
administration is just
blowing everything that the u.s has ever
spent really out of the water
and i've heard you talk a lot about how
republicans only say oh we care about
the debt but when they're in charge
they don't care about the debt and i
fully get that but what is your
perspective on the debt
i mean are you are you not worried about
uh the the debt that u.s is
amassing right now so there's a couple
different things here um
first of all what when you look at the
debt you have to look at it
relative to the size of the economy so
the first
the first principle is just because the
debt is going up in terms of the number
of dollars
i'm more concerned with what it looks
like relative to the size of the economy
if the economy keeps growing and the
debt grows proportionally
i don't see that as a problem
objectively that's number one
um number two joe biden did the stimulus
package
and then there's some other things that
that imply spending via executive order
but
i mean you know the tax reform hasn't
passed
uh stimulus i'm sorry infrastructure
hasn't passed so
other than covid stimulus what are you
referring to
well i'm just thinking about the agenda
that some of the democrats are pushing
for
um i i get the sense that a lot of
democrats in the us want to
sort of transform the us into a social
democracy and european style
but um for example i live in denmark and
the minimum tax rate here is 37
income tax and i don't know if they have
the guts to
to raise the taxes in proportion to the
spending that they're going to do
so you it sounds like you're assuming
that taxes have to be raised
in relation to the spending they want to
do but that's not necessarily the case
but but the the spending of the united
states has really
increased a lot especially under obama
and under trump
so it actually relatively so the deficit
actually went down under obama it was
still
positive which edged up the national
debt trump did come in
promising to pay off the national debt
in one term
he actually accelerated deficit growth i
think maybe
lucas the the the problem is you know
you started with wanting me to comment
on all the spending biden has done but
then when i pointed out
he's really only done covet stimulus he
said well there's a lot of democrats who
want to do spending which is a
completely different thing that hasn't
passed yet and they'll have to present
to us how they will pay for the spending
that they want to do
so we're kind of moving the goal posts a
little bit here yeah
but would you then be in favor of
something for example in germany they
they have a law that you're not allowed
to spend more than you earn
over two percent annually uh i mean i
get your argument but would you be in
favor of something like that i mean
you know i would i wouldn't and i'll
tell you why i'll tell you why i
wouldn't be in favor of that
there are types of deficit spending
that over the medium to long term are
deficit negative and are economically
stimulative
and uh they are often a lot of the
bigger projects that i think would be
important for
the country to do and so to to simply
arbitrarily say
you can't go two percent in spending
beyond revenues when you might be able
to do something
that would cost you net money in the
first or even second third year
but would be a big boon to the country
over the long term
there's no i don't see any reason to
artificially
uh handicap the ability of our leaders
to to do things in that way i don't see
the benefit of it particularly the more
we learn about
modern monetary theory long term
something will have to be done right i
mean you can't continue on this path
forever i think you you understand that
right
yeah i totally get your point it's not
clear to me you know i mean here's the
thing
it not all economists agree that we
can't continue on this path forever
again if you look at our monetary theory
is really
something that that is highly
theoretical
and being pushed by some of the new
economists a lot of people disagree
many people disagree but understand that
many of the things that neoclassical
and keynesian economics tell us are only
slightly older ideas and they regularly
fail to actually function
according to neoclassical and keynesian
economics
the u.s should should have seen over the
last 20 years
absolutely explosive inflation and it
hasn't happened why hasn't it happened
are you also going around saying
all of the neoclassical economists are
wrong
no i don't think so but for example uh
the
um interest rates have been very very
low yeah so it has been
it has been very cheap to take on debt
but i think now that we are we are in so
much that it becomes
very hard to push interest rates up
again to rates where we had them uh
previously of the financial crisis
okay and so what so then the inflation
will come when
i don't i don't know about inflation i'm
just a student i really don't know a lot
about the economics but what i do know
is that
the us is is uh taking on a lot of debt
and so are
countries in europe and i just i can't
see why that would be
healthy in the absolute long term yeah
it's not um
i get the idea you seem to be applying
sort of like household economics
to macro economies and there's a lot of
really good
academic scholarship about why it's just
the wrong paradigm through which we
should be thinking about it
well i would disagree but i think we're
short on time i bet you want to move on
so
i respect that well i mean you disagree
but you also said you're not really
you don't really know about economics
right well
i'm i'm i'm gonna study economics i
don't really know
a lot about it yet but i think i'm i'm
just
sort of uh not really i'm not sure where
i stand yet
but uh some people say that that is very
dangerous some people say
we shouldn't worry about it um but but
then what
well i think
both of those are very black and white
views debt doesn't matter or debt is
very dangerous
what increasingly seems to be the case
is that we have to apply a more nuanced
view
and say taking on debt to do certain
things
and in certain cases is okay and then
simply increasing the money supply to
pay debt
maybe is not so good right so i think we
just have to look at things in a more
nuanced
way yeah maybe we should
yeah but all right lucas yeah yeah thank
you very much appreciate the call
let's take a very quick break don't hang
up if you're holding because when we
come back i'm going to go right back
and talk to more people stand by